[Applaus]
[Musik]
die ganze welt sieht die bilder was mit
den flüchtlingen auf dem meer passiert
alles was in diesen bildern sichtbar ist
haben wir erlebt wir sterben nur nicht
jeder mensch ist auf seine erde seine
stadt seine heimat stolz wenn der mensch
nicht gezwungen ist flieht er nicht aus
seiner heimat
ich habe auf vieles verzichtet alles was
ich in 58 jahren erarbeitet habe musste
ich zurück lassen wenn man hierher kommt
will man sich beengt sehr beengt
[Musik]
über viele jahre habe ich das politische
engagement dieser kurdischen menschen
aus der ferne mit verfolgt ich bin
selbst kurde und lebe seit drei
jahrzehnten in der schweiz die
politischen vorgänge in meinem
herkunftsland interessiere mich noch
immer sehr ich war überrascht als ich
erfuhr dass diese prominenten männer die
ich bis anhin nur aus den medien kannte
heute als anerkannte flüchtlinge in der
schweiz leben
sie erzählen mir wie sie diesen abrupten
schnitt in ihrer biografie erlebt haben
und vor welchen herausforderungen sie
nun stehen fragt und islam handel eben
in bern slam ist ärztin fahrt jurist
bevor er vor drei jahren in die schweiz
kam war fortan oberbürgermeister der
stadt am edt die abag ihren mit rund
anderthalb millionen einwohnern
ich wurde in alt geworden
ich habe mein ganzes leben in dieser
stadt verbracht hier wohnten zum
internet haben in jedem quartier der
stadt gewohnt in der altstadt von matt
innerhalb des stadttore und auch im
neuen stadtteil
deshalb bin ich mit dieser stadt
besonders vertraut als jurist habe ich
in armut für angeles gearbeitet
menschenrechts vereine und sonstige
organisationen die sich für die rechte
der kurdischen bevölkerung eingesetzt
haben
ich war für die anwaltskammer von ahmet
aktiv für menschenrechts vereine und
politische parteien im jahr 2014 wurde
fragt alle gemeinsam mit gütern kita zum
bürgermeister der kurdischen stadt damit
gewählt das system der doppelvertretung
von je einer frau und einem mann in
politischen ämtern ist ein grundprinzip
der kurdischen bewegung eigentlich
hatten an land geschah hat große pläne
doch nach drei jahren im amt wurden die
beiden von der regierung abgesetzt und
verhaftet alle verbrauchte neun monate
in untersuchungshaft bevor er in die
schweiz flüchtete seine amtskollegin ist
noch immer die nacht irrt
dort kannte ich 20.000 menschen
das alles musste ich zurück lassen das
ist mein größter verlust ihre erste kann
nicht keinen mehr kontaktieren
vor allem bist du fremd bedeutet dass
ein fremdes land eine fremde
gesellschaft eine fremde sprache
ich war seit 1990 biologielehrer an
verschiedenen gymnasien in der provinz
ankara in der türkei war es
staatsangestellten verboten sich
gewerkschaftlich zu organisieren
im jahr 1990 haben wir gesagt dass wir
aufgrund des internationalen pakts de
facto das recht haben eine gewerkschaft
zu gründen
es gelang uns dann tatsächlich war dann
lehrer aktivist und gewerkschaftsführer
lamy özkan hatte seit den 90er jahren
verschiedene einflussreiche ämter bei
der lehrergewerkschaft inne
zuletzt vertrat er als co präsident des
gewerkschaftsbundes cas die anliegen von
rund 240.000 angestellten im
öffentlichen sektor dass ein
einflussreicher unerschrockener
gewerkschafter sich gegen die parolen
der staatspolitik stellt missfiel den
machthabern in der türkei lam ii sgn
wurde verfolgt und sah sich schließlich
zur flucht gezwungen
seit 2017 lebt er in bern ich bin
geschieden und habe eine tochter ist
kürzlich 21 jahre alt geworden
sie studiert an der universität
sie hat zunächst in ankara studiert
wegen problemen gegen meinen problemen
war es ihr nicht mehr möglich in der
türkei zu studieren
sie studiert seit letztem oktober an der
humboldt universität in berlin chemie
[Musik]
wie viele wackler
nicht mit diesem messer es geht schon an
meinem pharmaziestudium ging ich nach
wartung 1992 eröffnete ich dort eine
eigene apotheke gleichen jahr ist meine
schwester als kämpferin für die
kurdische arbeiterpartei in wan gefallen
daraufhin haben die behörden die arbeit
mit mir abgebrochen mit der begründung
ich sei der bruder einer terroristin
ich habe finanzielle schwierigkeiten
bekommen darum bin ich nach antalya
ausgewandert nach zehn jahren in antalya
kehrte demir celik zurück in seine
heimatstadt wartung und kandidierte dort
auf wunsch der bevölkerung für das
bürgermeisteramt noch eine amtsperiode
als bürgermeister machte er auch in der
nationalen politik von sich reden er war
gründer präsident der linksliberalen
kurdischen partei bdp die bei den
parlamentswahlen im jahr 2011 große
erfolge verbuchte demir celik war bis
2015 abgeordneter im türkischen
nationalparlament demir und sol gel
schillig leben seit rund vier jahren im
kanton bern
vor kurzem sind sie aufs land in die
kleine einliegerwohnung im haus eines
kurdischen freundes gezogen
das ehepaar zwei söhne eine von ihnen
folgte ihnen in die schweiz und lebt in
bern
wie läuft es bei euch es läuft deine
mutter und ich kennen uns gegenseitig
wir sind beschäftigt mit dem garten
wir kommen zurecht es geht nicht
schlecht aber auch nicht besonders gut
als ich in die schweiz kam gab es bei
der berufungsinstanz 13 hängige urteile
gegen mich nachdem ich in die schweiz
gekommen bin kamen immer mehr verfahren
hinzu heute sind es 37 strafverfahren
und zwei dieser verfahren wurde ich nun
rechtskräftig verurteilt einmal sechs
jahre und drei monate und einmal drei
jahre
es steht eine gefängnisstrafe von neun
jahren und drei monaten gegen mich
[Musik]
wir haben geredet und unsere meinung zur
sprache gebracht
wir haben vorschläge für die lösung der
kurdenfrage gemacht aber sie sagen das
sei gemäß der türkischen verfassung und
den geltenden gesetzen verboten
die regierung sagt der maßstab ist dass
wir uns nur innerhalb der türkischen
ideologie äußern dürfen
das haben wir nicht akzeptiert wir
machen politik
es ist die aufgabe der politik probleme
zu lösen
ich habe in der türkei an der
politischen akademie zu der idee einer
demokratischen selbstverwaltung
unterrichtet hat etwa 80 millionen
einwohner in der türkei leben nicht nur
türken sondern auch araber vergessen
blasen kurden yeziden assyrer muslime
sowie christen wir wollten dass diese
vielfalt von völkern in mesopotamien und
anatolien anerkannt wird
die wollten wir das erreichen in einem
kantonalen system wie in der schweiz
[Musik]
das buch ist jetzt in der türkei
verboten
nun wird mit der stadt vor ich hätte die
ideologie hinter der selbstverwaltung
und den städte kämpfen durch die
veröffentlichung eines buches
hervorgebracht es ist eine neue anklage
erhoben worden wegen der gefährdung der
staats einheit fordert der staat eine
lebenslängliche gefängnisstrafe
[Musik]
wenn du deine muttersprache spricht
sagen sie du dienst im terror
wenn du deinen glauben lebst sagen sie
du dienst im terror
wenn du in diesem staat nicht türken
bist nicht muslimisch und von konfession
hanifi team also nicht hin wenn du nicht
die gleiche denkweise hast dienst du dem
terror
[Musik]
und wann beginnt ein zweites semester
[Gelächter]
kommen
ich habe zweimal versucht zu fliehen
beim ersten mal musste ich auf halben
weg kehrt machen das kleine boot auf dem
großen mehr kommt ihr wie ein stück
papier vor
mit uns auf dem boot waren frauen und
kinder
obwohl die eltern bei ihnen waren kinder
sind etwas besonderes
ich schreie der kinder hinterlassen
tiefe spuren gehen viele gedanken durch
den kopf längst an den tod denkt an sein
früheres leben
das schwierigste ist dass du dich fragst
warum du das über sich ergehen lassen
muss der türkische staat ist autoritär
und bereit gewalt anzuwenden
in so einem land muss man sich auch für
die demokratie stark machen
es war schwierig weil wir haben auf den
kopf hingehalten
hier wurden einige male angegriffen ich
weiß heute gar nicht mehr wie viele male
wir verhaftet und mit knüppeln und
tränengas angegriffen wurden
wenn du dich für die demokratie einsetzt
die dich geben den schmutzigen krieg
gegen die kurden stellst und die für den
frieden stark machst dann bist du immer
im visier der behörden
im jahr 2009 das jahr 2009 ist für die
geschichte der türkei wichtig in diesem
jahr gingen die behörden gegen kurdische
politiker gewerkschafter und
journalisten vor immer wieder wurden die
leute verhaftet und angeklagt
auch wir die funktionäre des
gewerkschaftsbundes cas wurden verhaftet
die aktivitäten unserer gewerkschaft
wurden kriminalisiert ameos can kam
zunächst für sechseinhalb monate in
untersuchungshaft und wurde schließlich
zu einer gefängnisstrafe von über sechs
jahren verurteilt er so wie tausende
weitere demokratische politikerinnen und
politiker wurden im rahmen des so
genannten kck prozesses der
mitgliedschaft bei der verbotenen
kurdischen arbeiterpartei beschuldigt
ziel dieser fingierten anklagen war die
ausschaltung der demokratischen
kurdischen opposition
mutmaßlich wie sie der machtkampf
zwischen der von der gülen bewegung
kontrollierten türkischen justiz und
erdogans regierung zum opfer
bittere tatsache ist dass der türkische
staat diese menschen zum teil jahrelang
in untersuchungshaft festhielt
manchmal komme ich auch durcheinander
wie oft ich in haft war vier mal oder
fünfmal
1995 wurde verhaftet
auch 1996 in ankara
1997 wurde ein haftbefehl erlassen
2009 wurde ich verhaftet gemeinsam mit
hunderten tausenden anderen weich wegen
des kck prozesses lange zeit in haft
2013 wurde ich freigelassen 2016 aber
schon wieder inhaftiert
ich war zehn monaten haft wieder
freigelassen
zwei tage später gab es schon einen
neuen haftbefehl
dieser steht immer noch aus
zuletzt richteten sich die anklagen
gegen meine arbeit als bürgermeister
alles was wir für unser volk und unsere
stadt getan haben wurde als eine
straftat betrachtet sie fragen warum
habt ihr das system der coburger
meisterschaft eingeführt dieses system
wurde als straftat eingestuft
zum beispiel habe ich am tag der
kurdischen sprache eine rede gehalten
sie sagen das sei eine straftat in der
letzten anklage werden mir und meiner
kollegin fergie chamakh ausschließlich
reden vorgeworfen ausschließlich reden
das ist die neujahrsfeier de france 2016
millionen von menschen kamen zusammen
frank schalla dich haben die leute
begrüßt es war keine rede mit
politischem inhalt
es war nur eine begrüßung in der anklage
wird das eine straftat betrachtet sie
folgern daraus die mitgliedschaft einer
illegalen organisation
es ist nichts strafbares daran
ich bin selbst jurist und ich weiß was
ich sagen darf und was nicht
du kannst das 100 mal anschauen es ist
unmöglich etwas strafbares darin zu
finden
liebe mitbürger hier an der newa ross
feier in der hauptstadt kurdistans
sollen wir den gefallenen kubaners und
den gefallenen unseres volkes unseren
respekt
wir verneigen uns vor den gefallenen
kurdistans wir versprechen dass sie in
unserem leben und in unserem streben
immer lebendig bleiben
millionen von chor und versammelt sich
das zieht weltweit aufmerksamkeit auf
sich
das ist es was sie eigentlich stört und
ärgert im herbst 2016 wurden fragt an
lee und gülten kita in einer nacht und
nebel aktion verhaftet
in der stadt waren heftige proteste aus
die staatsanwaltschaft forderte eine
lebenslängliche gefängnisstrafe für
freitag die anklage lautete wieder auf
mitgliedschaft oder gar führung der
bewaffneten kurdischen arbeiterpartei
ich frage fragt an etwas an diesen
vorwürfen dran ist
bezug auf meiner rede am evros fest
behaupten soll
murat karayilan hat das volk kurdistans
zur niveaus feier aufgerufen du bist am
aufruf gefolgt damit ist die sache klar
du bist teil der organisation ich habe
weder gewalt befürwortet noch gewalt
angewendet
noch werde ich mich jemals dazu
herablassen hätte anrecht auf eine
dienstwaffe der hat das wollte ich nicht
als ich mitglied des nationalparlaments
war hätte ich anrecht auf eine
dienstwaffe gehabt ich wollte das nicht
eine pistole eine waffe das ist für mich
etwas kaltes es ist wie eine schlange
ich weiß nicht ob ich über diese
vorwürfe gegen uns lachen oder weinen
soll
es ist gleichzeitig die komödie und die
tragödie des türkischen staates der
türkischen justiz während eines amtszeit
als oberbürgermeister kann es zu einer
freundschaft brücke zwischen den städten
zürich und damit welche einen großen
symbolwert für die kurdische bevölkerung
sowohl in der schweiz als auch in der
türkei hatte
in diesem rahmen macht den anleihe und
seine amtskollegin gütern geschmack im
herbst 2016 einen besuch in zürich
bei dieser gelegenheit trafen sie auch
stadtpräsidentin corine mauch
guten tag
das ist sehr nett ganz herzlichen darum
geht es ihnen so schön glänzt in der
schweiz und ich höre sie sprechen
aber wenn ich muss sie lernen
sehr schön ich habe eine starke
erinnerung an den besuch von ihnen und
frauke sanac hier und ich möchte sie
fragen wie geht es frau kaiser s drauf
ich übergebe ihnen ein dossier mit der
neuesten informationen zu ihrer
situation
vor vier jahren haben forscher mag und
ich uns hier mit ihnen unterhalten über
die aktuelle situation
es hat uns sehr gefreut was wir in
zürich erfahren und gesehen haben
diese erfahrungen wollten wir in a mat
de bakker umsetzen
doch leider hat sich dieser wunsch nicht
das wird wir wurden drei wochen nach
unserer rückkehr verhaftet
jack ist seit vier jahren im gefängnis
von coach eli 1000 kilometer von
gladbacher entfernt
ist bei den kurden und in der türkei
sehr bekannt für ihren einsatz für die
rechte der frauen hat sie teuer bezahlt
wir hoffen sehr dass sie ihre freiheit
bald zurück hat natürlich überlegt wie
können wir sie unterstützen und ich habe
mich persönlich auch antrag ist ein
abgewandt um ihr zu sagen die
solidarität von unserer seite und auch
dass wir dass sie nicht allein ist die
stelle mir das vor meister nicht mehr
bin ich jetzt vergessen gegangen oder
denkt über haben ob jemand mich dass wir
in den gedanken bei ihr sind sie hat mir
dann auch geantwortet dass das für sie
sehr wichtig war
ich habe großen respekt davor damals
schon habe ich das gespürt dass sie
unter sehr viel schwierigeren umständen
für ihre werte und ihre ziele einstellen
müssen und die verhaftung hatte dann
auch gezeigt dass sie wirklich
ernsthafte persönliche risiken eingeben
gehen um das zu tun und das verlangt mir
großen respekt und ich wünsche ihnen
alles konnte grüßen sie noch unbekannter
weise in den frauen und ihre kinder sehr
gerne von mir
[Musik]
das demokratisch gewählte bürgermeister
einfach abgesetzt und verhaftet werden
hat in der türkei system zwar dass der
staat wahlen zu respektiert dann jedoch
den volksentscheid nicht wenn die wahl
auf einen nicht regierungstreuen
kandidatenfeld im märz 2009 10 wurden
ansell schuppen fraglich und julia
alpmann mit überwältigender mehrheit ins
bürgermeisteramt von armut gewählt
bereits wenige monate nach amtsantritt
wurden sie abgesetzt
beide befinden sich noch immer in haft
dass die politik sich die justiz das
instrument der unterdrückung
oppositionelle stimmen zu nutze macht
ist schon lange in themen der türkei
diese willkür zerstört leben all meine
protagonisten mussten dies am eigenen
leib erfahren
[Musik]
der vorsitzende des gerichts in izmir
das uns verurteilt hat hatte sich gegen
das urteil gestellt unsere aktivitäten
seien gewerkschaftlich und demokratisch
gewesen
sie durften nicht kriminalisiert werden
er hat damit gegen die beiden anderen
richter argumentiert die ihm unterstellt
waren
er sei die verurteilung war damals eine
staatspolitik diese beiden richter
handelten im auftrag des
justizministeriums
sie kam nach diesem jahr nahmen an einer
einzigen verhandlung teil und haben das
urteil gefällt
in st gallen trifft lamy esken seinen
rechtsvertreter sharif aus dem lokal der
ihnen der schweiz vom ersten moment an
begleitet hat
sheriff kam selber in den 80er jahren
als flüchtling in die schweiz und
studiert in fribourg jura er kennt die
rechtssysteme beider länder
ich habe festgestellt dass er aufgrund
einer konstruierten sachverhalts
verurteilt wurde
denn ihm wurde die mitgliedschaft in
einer terroristischen organisation
vorgeworfen was überhaupt nicht zutrifft
so ein urteil wäre in der schweiz nicht
zulässig weil es den grundprinzipien
eines rechtsstaats widerspricht ein
putschversuch im juli 2016 veränderte
die machtverhältnisse in der türkei
schlagartig erdogan beschuldigte gülen
als drahtzieher und ging hart gegen die
mutmaßlichen mitglieder seiner bewegung
vor von der folgenden verhaftungswelle
waren auch hochrangige mitglieder des
kühlen netzwerks in der türkischen
justiz betroffen
trotz allem wurde das umstrittene urteil
gegen liu scan 2017 vom obersten
gerichtshof bestätigt
die beiden richter wurden entlassen und
verhaftet mit dem vorwurf dass sie
mitglieder einer illegalen organisation
sein
wir sind noch im gefängnis
um den zustand der effektiven
unterdrückung der kurdischen politischen
bewegung zu erhalten setzt der staat
enorme kräfte ein
dabei ist es noch nicht lange her dass
ein anderer weg möglich schien der die
hoffnung auf eine friedliche lösung
aufblühen dies im jahr 2013 dies
erdogans regierung einen weisenrat
bilden über 60 bekannte intellektuelle
darunter auch lange scan sollten das
land bereisen um die meinung der
bevölkerung zur politischen lösung des
jahrhundertealten kurdenproblems zu
hören
[Musik]
zu dieser zeit kam etwas gutes zu stande
es begannen die gespräche zwischen dem
staat und der kurdischen bewegung für
friedensbemühungen
das war eine neue entwicklung eine sache
die nie zuvor da gewesen war
nachdem erdogan jedoch im sommer 2015
mit den ultra nationalistischen kräften
der türkei ein bündnis eingegangen war
um seine macht zu erhalten viel der
weisenrat in ungnade
lammers kennt vermutet dass die neuen
staats kräfte die aufkündigung der
friedensgespräche mit der erstarrten
kurdischen bewegung zu einer bedingung
ihrer unterstützung machten
zu hause zeigt mir am ersten einladungen
hier bernd seinerzeit das
gewerkschaftspräsident erhalten hat es
sind große namen vom türkischen
staatspräsidenten bis zur schweizer
botschaft in ankara
ich frage ihn welche bedeutung die
bekanntheit von damals für ihn heute
noch hat ein kurdisches sprichwort sagt
die welt dreht sich mal bist oben und
mal bist du unten außen an lee und ihre
beiden kinder im alter von elf und 15
jahren dürften erst im august 2009 10
zwei jahre nach flatterndes flucht in
die schweiz einreisen
für die familie begann endlich wieder
ein gemeinsamer alltag gezeichnet von
der herausforderung in einem fremden
land sein neues leben zu beginnen
lehmanns lehrerin hat ihm gesagt dass
sie weiß dass er noch nicht alles
versteht es aber sicher bald lernen wird
das hat ihm gut getan um die motiviert
ist froh dass man verständnis für seine
situation hat er ist auch froh dass sie
merkt wie sehr er sich bemüht im
vergleich zum letzten jahr geht es ihm
jetzt besser da hat sich gut eingelebt
letztes jahr musste er noch keine
prüfungen machen dieses jahr schon je
mehr freunde er findet desto wohler wird
er sich fühlen denn es ist sehr
schwierig eine neue sprache und ein
neues system kennen zu lernen
ein neues leben aufzubauen
familien muss all dieser schwierigkeiten
mittragen das lässt einen verzweifeln
mein sohn von der schule nach hause und
hat geweint
er hat gesagt ich bin kein denn ich bin
nicht dumm verstehe die sprache einfach
nicht und er wisse nicht was die lehrer
sagen wir haben heute im sportunterricht
übungen mit dem basketball gemacht
danach haben wir die geschichte aus
einem buch nachgespielt deshalb habe ich
lege los in die schule genommen
das haben wir heute gemacht wie viele
figuren hattest du 5 mein eindruck ist
dass du seit beginn des schuljahrs
besser verstehst ja das stimmt ich
verstehe berndeutsch ist besser ich
werde in der schule auch unterstützt
kürzlich hatten wir einen kleinen test
und das lief gut
positiv der ort carey artikel akkusativ
da die adidas wie verändern sich dieser
artikel im akkusativ am meisten mache
ich diesen fehler im akkusativ verändert
sich nur der maskuline artikel der die
und das bleiben unverändert
was die sprache angeht bist du sturm die
leute die ich etwas fragen bist du bist
wirklich wie taub du verstehst einfach
nichts zudem ist zu weit weg von deiner
familie von deinen freunden deiner
heimat der kampf den du geführt hast ist
stehen geblieben waren sie schon einmal
auf etwas oder auf jemanden neidisch
neidig auch stolz auf
ich gebe mir große mühe aber die
deutsche sprache ist sehr komplex und
reich ich habe zwei abgeschlossen und
jetzt mit c1 begonnen
für die person
manchmal brauchen wir diesen die
arbeitsintegration betrifft ich habe
hier einen beruf biologie ist auf der
ganzen welt anerkannt wenn ich die
sprache gut genug sprechen könnte hätte
ich als biologe viele
arbeitsmöglichkeiten
auch wenn es schwierig ist werde ich es
schaffen
so sehe ich es
[Musik]
hier musst du wieder von null anfangen
im alter von 40 50 jahren musst du ein
neues leben beginnen allem was man bis
anhin erarbeitet hat tatsächlich liebe
ich meinen beruf die schere masek hast
gibt ihnen hier wieder aufzunehmen
scheint sehr schwierig zu sein
wir haben hoffnung dass meine frau die
ärztin ist irgendwann in ihrem beruf
arbeiten kann
sie hat über 20 jahre als ärztin
gearbeitet und hat viel erfahrung
wir wollen uns so schnell wie möglich
mit unseren fähigkeiten in die
gesellschaft einbringen
wir haben die heimat zurück gelassen
wir mussten weg
wir haben unser dorf zurückgelassen
unser haus
wenn wir dort nicht reich waren waren
wir immerhin unabhängig
hier sind wir auf den staat angewiesen
schweiz ist ein demokratisches land mit
schöner natur
aber es ist nicht unsere heimat indem
ihr uns songs trauer um ihre heimat
mischt sich auch die sorge um den
zweiten sohn he wahl im jahr 2013
schloss er sich den bewaffneten truppen
der kurdischen arbeiterpartei an
wir haben ihm gesagt du studierst jura
der der anwalt und setze dich so für die
demokratie ein
er sagte das reicht mir nicht
du bist politiker fast apotheker
bürgermeister parteipräsident und
abgeordneter das hast du erreicht die
kurdenfrage ist nicht gelöst
ich vermisse meinen sohn sehen wie jede
mutter das tun würde
keine mutter wünscht dass ihr sohn
stirbt selbst wenn er glaubt sich für
etwas gerechtes einzusetzen
jahrelang hofften die eltern auf ein
lebenszeichen ihres sohnes dann im
oktober 2020 berichten türkische medien
über seine festnahme
doch die eltern können keinen kontakt zu
ihr aufnehmen
[Musik]
seit langem scan in der schweiz legte
auch kontakte zu den hiesigen
gewerkschaften und verfolgt deren arbeit
mit großem interesse den
erfahrungsaustausch mit den kollegen
schätzt er sehr leicht in diesen drei
jahren hat lange relativ viel gelernt
nicht nur die sprache auch die
gewerkschaften kennengelernt die
diplomatie kulturen der gewerkschaft und
sagen ich jetzt mal dass der parteien
hat er alles dann wirklich gut
gemeistert
also du warst ja in der türkei eine hoch
bekannte politische persönlichkeit wie
erlebst du was also wie ist das für dich
plötzlich auch einen gefunden hofs tief
hinunter zu kommen
in der türkei man muss nicht nur als
gewerkschafter treten kann fehlt
gesellschaft werden
problemen kämpfen 30 jahre wir haben so
viel gemacht aber hier in der schweiz
für mich gibt es nicht so viele
aktivitäten wir haben verstärkt mit
gewerkschaften und politischer parteien
und verschiedenen plattformen aber nicht
gleich ich fühle mich gut aber manchmal
unnötig viele milch nicht dass die
erlebnisse in der türkei haben bei
larsen tiefe spuren hinterlassen er
zeigt mir bilder von einem anschlag im
jahr 2015 der das ganze land erschüttert
hat sami selbst war mittendrin
wir waren mitten in ankara
doch die ambulanz least 30 minuten auf
sich warten es wurde einfach nicht
geschickt
die ambulanz wurde behindert viele
schwerverletzte wurden mit taxis sind
spital gebracht
wir haben sie mit taxis ins spital
geschickt
die ambulanz kam erst eine halbe stunde
später
der gewerkschaftsbund kess und drei
weitere bedeutende berufsverbände
organisierten im oktober 2015 eine
friedenskundgebung in ankara
nachdem es nach drei jahren relativer
ruhe wieder zu schweren bewaffneten
kämpfen gekommen war
über 100.000 menschen kamen zusammen und
forderten ein ende der gewalt ein durch
den islamischen staat verübte anschlag
auf die friedliche kundgebung forderte
er 103 tote und über 500 verletzte
naviscan macht den türkischen staat
direkt für den anschlag verantwortlich
inzwischen ist alles herausgekommen dass
der geheimdienst und der staat von
diesem anschlag gewusst haben
die täter wurden unterstützt weißt du
als wir das am anfang sagten
akzeptierten sie es nicht später haben
es ihre eigenen untersuchung
beauftragten in ihren berichten belegt
sie haben den anschlag bewusst nicht
verhindert weil es ihnen für die
bevorstehenden wahlen 2015 einen vorteil
verschaffte sinnlosen anschlag wollten
sie die opposition einschüchtern
also viele menschen kamen liefen wir
hundert meter weiter vorne wir das nicht
getan wären wir anstelle der anderen
gestorben
wir haben überlebt aber an unserer
stelle sind unsere freunde gestorben
wenn ich die bilder von diesem massaker
wiedersehen oder wir die bilder haben
immer noch große auswirkungen auf nicht
es ist jedes mal als würde ich es von
neuem erleben
ich weiß dass ich keine schuld habe aber
wir werden dieses massaker nicht
vergessen ich werde es nie vergessen
manfred alle sind die erlebnisse der
vergangenen jahrzehnte nicht spurlos
vorüber gegangen der tod seines engen
freundes und weggefährten tahir lg
bewegt die noch heute zutiefst teenager
war vorsitzende der anwaltskammer in
java kühe und über jahrzehnte eine
schlüsselfigur in der
menschenrechtsbewegung in der türkei
er wurde mehrmals verhaftet und mehrmals
schwer gefoltert
aber teil gab nie auf lg war ein pionier
der viele verfahren vor dem europäischen
menschenrechtsgerichtshof brachte er hat
hunderte verfahren dorthin gebracht
während andere angst hatten ihre
unterschrift unter eine akte zu setzen
ging daher in kurdistan von dorf zu dorf
und bot sich als verteidiger
an jenem tag war ich bei einer
buchvernissage bei der es um die
historische brücke mit zehn toren über
den fluss tigris ging das war mein
programm an jenem samstag morgen etwas
ungeduldig denn eigentlich wollte ich
bei anrufen
ich spreche zum ersten mal darüber teil
lg gab im november 2015 vor einem
historischen minaretten in jarabacoa
dass in den tagen zuvor mutwillig
beschädigt worden war
eine presse erklärung ab in der er das
ende der gewalt in den kurdischen
gebieten forderte noch während seiner
ansprache wurde er von einer kugel
getroffen die in einem feuergefecht
zwischen der polizei und einer pkk nahen
jugendorganisation abgegeben worden war
ich hörte plötzlich schüsse
ich habe tage angerufen aber ein anderer
hat abgenommen
ein journalist rief mich an
er sagte es gebe schlechte nachrichten
ich ging ins leichenschauhaus auf den
tisch geladen
ich habe ihn umarmt ich sah wie seine
stirn noch bedeutete
ich weiß nicht ob es polizisten waren
die noch im raum waren
ich habe sie weggeschickt dann habe ich
geweint ich habe niemanden zu ihm
gelassen ich habe ihnen sehr lange
umarmt
[Musik]
jon kyl und demir celik haben zahlreiche
verwandte und freunde die ihre heimat
schon jahre zuvor verlassen mussten und
nun verstreut in westeuropa leben zu
diesen pflegen sie einen engen kontakt
heute ladens onkel und demir sollen
gemeinsamen essen ein
meine nerven haben mich von beginn an
unterstützt
ich musste keinen einzigen tag in einer
asylunterkunft verbringen zweifellos war
mein onkel nicht nur in der familie
sondern in der ganzen region eine
bekannte persönlichkeit
man fragt sich wie er als flüchtling
einen neuanfang machen kann
das macht einen traurig so etwas zu
sehen
es hätte nicht so weit kommen dürfen
kaum war meine mutter hier begann er mit
voller energie deutsch zu lernen
diszipliniert was er dafür jeden tag
eine stunde am computer
es ist unsere kultur wir wollen zusammen
kommen
darum haben wir heute gäste wir wollen
unsere beziehungen warm halten da wir
weit weg von der heimat sind wir wollen
dass unsere kinder einander kennen so
geht die kultur nicht verloren
[Musik]
der scan und fragt alle kennen sich seit
jahrzehnten ihre politische arbeit war
von derselben vision geprägt ein
demokratisches und freiheitliches land
mitzugestalten und auch wenn der preis
für ihr politisches engagement sehr hoch
war
ist ihre vision immer noch lebendig in
der schweiz sehen sie viele dinge die
sie in ihrer heimat gerne umsetzen
würden zum beispiel ein netz
touristischer wanderwege stell dir vor
zb im landkreis passau
ich hatte schon etliche projekte im kopf
nur leider hat er krieg nicht aufgehört
am berg an job und drosch ihn gibt es
viele geeignete orte butter käse brot
es gibt geeignete berge der berg an dog
ist zum skifahren fantastisch geeignet
im sommer und herbst kann man dort
wandern
du kannst dich sicher auch noch erinnern
vor 1980 kamen touristen nach ahmet vor
der großen moschee und vordenker hakten
touristenbusse nach dem militärputsch
1980 kam auf einmal niemand mehr weil
die region militarisiert worden war
wir haben drei vier jahre gearbeitet um
die stadtmauer von armut und die f cell
gärten in das unesco-weltkulturerbe
aufnehmen zu lassen
doch tausende solcher kulturstätten die
noch überhaupt nicht entdeckt worden
sind
[Musik]
kochen mit seiner tochter in berlin hat
die semesters examen sehr gut
superonline examiner gar nicht kämen
nicht gut nicht schlecht aber nicht
kommen ja noch mal über andere sondern
wir sind jetzt sehr schön aber alles
gestanden
[Musik]
ich habe die schweizer gesellschaft
etwas kennen gelernt ich habe freunde in
der schweiz gefunden und finde immer
mehr
[Musik]
tradition
wir haben ein bisschen weniger für das
p2 gemacht aber dafür uns sehr gut
kennen gelernt und ich habe eine
freundschaft geworden und keine keine
lehrer schüler beziehung sondern
wirklich eine freundschaft es ist
atemberaubend von dir zu erzählt
bekommen was du durchgemacht hast deinen
lebenslauf diese freundschaft für
lieblich dankbar
danke
celik trifft im haus der kulturen in
bern ihre verwandten und freunde alle
sind aktive mitglieder des kulturvereins
berger heute wird die jährliche chem
zeremonie gefeiert zu der menschen aus
der ganzen schweiz angereist sind
[Musik]
unser kerzenlicht ist für die hoffnung
dass alle menschen auf der welt in
frieden und freiheit leben können so
celik ist es ein großes anliegen die
kurdisch alevitische kultur
sie nennt sie rehag den weg der wahrheit
auch hier in der schweiz zu pflegen
sie betont die gleichberechtigung in
ihre kultur und möchte den natur-
glauben der stark von gesang tanz und
dichtung geprägtes mit einem modernen
religionsverständnis in einklang bringen
[Musik]
wenn ich hier in die berge fahren kommt
mir meine jugend in den sinn
schönste war dass man frei und mitten in
der natur
genau wie jetzt hier die natur gibt mir
kraft
diese pflanze gibt es überall auch in
kurdistan
es gibt zwei und drei blättrigen arten
die dreiblättrigen sind ein wichtiger
nahrungsbestandteile für scharfe weil
sie einen hohen proteingehalt haben
die
[Musik]
ich frage lamy osken ob die schweiz je
seine heimat werden kann
man sagt ja jede pflanze wächst auf
ihren eigenen wurzeln weißt du als ich
hierher kam war ich 55 jahre alt für
meinen alltag kann die schweiz eine
heimat werden aber für eine wirkliche
heimat ist es schwierig meine wurzeln
sind nicht hier meine wurzeln meine erde
sind dort eine erde ist kurdistan
[Musik]
dort hast du eine identität einen status
seinen platz in der gesellschaft
ich wollte in armut sagen mir ihr habt
es sehr gut
er lebt in diesem schönen land schweiz
mitten im paradies auf erden herbert
witte ich habe hier freunde und kann ein
neues leben beginnen
aber wenn ich die möglichkeit hätte
würde ich keine minute länger hier
bleiben
[Musik]